nach der Wiederholungswahl in Berlin da
sah es ja zumindest kurz danach erst
einmal so aus als ob Rot-Grün rot
weitermacht Silke gebe
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Grünen im Roten
Rathaus ich frag sie jetzt einfach mal
hätten Sie gerne weiter regiert und auf
welchem Weg hat denn ihre Partei das
überhaupt erfahren dass sie im Prinzip
ja dass sie raus sind
der wir als Grüne haben glaube ich in
den letzten sechs Jahren auch sehr
deutlich gemacht dass wir den
Regierungsauftrag ernst nehmen dass wir
Berlin beim Klimaschutz umgebaut haben
dass wir mehr Radwege gebaut haben
insofern hätten wir natürlich gerne
diesen Gestaltungsauftrag weiter
wahrgenommen ähm wir hatten auch gute
Sondierungen und
haben dann leider aus den Medien
entnommen dass die SPD ähm entgegen der
Gespräche die montags stattgefunden
haben und der Absprachen die dort
getroffen worden sich am Mittwoch noch
mal zu verständigen dass es eben dann am
Dienstag von ihrer Seite dazu kam mit
der CDU in kurz und Verhandlung zu gehen
wie waren ihre Reaktionen bei ihnen in
der Partei im Landesvorstand von Bündnis
90 die Grünen das sieht das aus den
Medien erfahren mussten
wenn man sechseinhalb Jahre doch dann
gut zusammenarbeitet wir haben ja die
corona-krise gemeistert wir haben die
Ukraine
Herausforderungen die er in Berlin auch
wirklich mit sehr sehr vielen
ankommenden den wir Hilfe geleistet
haben sich niedergeschlagen haben und
den sozialen Hilfen die wir da angeboten
haben also wir sind sozusagen als
Koalition rot grün rot in den letzten
sechseinhalb Jahren auch sehr viele
Herausforderungen unserer Zeit schnell
ähm eingegangen und haben auch glaube
ich gute Lösungen herbeigeführt und
haben gleichzeitig auch diesen Anspruch
die Stadt in die Klimakrise zu führen
soziale Gerechtigkeit herzustellen immer
wieder gespürt und wahrgenommen und da
ist es doch sehr seltsam überraschend
und auch ein ganz klarer Vertrauensbruch
wenn man dann von einem
Koalitionspartner aus der Zeitung
erfährt dass sie sich für jemand anderen
entschieden haben was ihr gutes Recht
ist die SPD ähm hat natürlich jederzeit
die Möglichkeiten eigene Kurskorrektur
vorzunehmen und sich Richtung CDU zu
entscheiden ich finde nur zumindest das
ist mein politischer Stil glaube ich
auch der Anstand dass man dann da eher
auch das persönlich Gespräch sucht aber
ich glaube da hat jeder seinen eigenen
Politikstil Bettina jarasch ihre
Spitzenkandidatin Senatorin hat ja vor
der Wahl gesagt nicht mit der CDU wie
waren denn die sandierungsgespräche es
gibt ja Themen wie z.B innere Sicherheit
klimaverkehr Migration wo sie mit der
CDU doch ich sag mal sehr weit
auseinander liegen
also wir haben vor der Wahl keine
demokratische Partei ausgeschlossen wir
hatten eine Präferenz für Rot Grün Rot
mit denen wir ja vor anderthalb Jahren
in Koalitionsvertrag abgeschlossen haben
ich glaube das ist dann auch erstmal
kein Geheimnis dass man sagt man
versucht dann auch den Weg weiterzugehen
der 2021 gegolten hat wir haben trotzdem
mit der CDU in den Gesprächen das da
kann ich den Eindruck von Kai Wegner nur
Teilen sehr ver ganz volle Gespräche
gehabt wir haben in dieser
sondierungsgruppe glaube ich alle
miteinander versucht diese Polarisierung
die sich mindestens im Wahlkampf aber
auch ein Stückchen darüber hinaus
niedergeschlagen hat die auch sage ich
mal in der Stadt sich niederschlägt das
ist
polarisierende Debatten gibt dazu gucken
wie kann man Gräben zuschütten wie kann
man zueinander finden wie kann man eben
nicht übereinander sondern miteinander
sprechen und was muss dafür passieren
indem man einfach die Menschen in den
Blick nimmt indem man gegenseitig die
Position auch noch mal auf eine andere
Art und Weise versteht und ich glaube da
ist auch auf jeden Fall noch mal neues
Vertrauen entstanden auch wenn natürlich
klar ist an vielen Stellen sind die
Perspektiven auch verkehrswände auf die
Priorität von Klimaschutz auf die
Weiterentwicklung von Anti
diskriminierungspolitik natürlich andere
aber ich glaube es ist gut dass wir
diesen Gespräch waren und das wird auf
jeden Fall noch Früchte tragen ja was
haben Sie sich denn jetzt vorgenommen
wenn sie in die Opposition gehen sollten
wie schwer wollen wollen Sie denn
schwarz-rot das Leben machen in der
Hauptstadt
man hat das ja eben auch gemerkt Kai
Wegner hat von großen Schnittmengen
gesprochen das macht einfach nur
deutlich dass es die Koalition der das
kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenners von Berlin
ist weil eben große Teile der
Bevölkerung da mutmaßlich mit ihren
Interessen nicht sich wiederfinden
insofern sehe ich auch als unsere
Aufgabe drin dass die Grünen dann die
Oppositionsführerin sind wir werden die
größte Fraktion im Parlament stellen und
dass wir dafür sorgen dass Klimaschutz
die Priorität hat dir nur mit uns in der
Regierung bekommen hätte dass die
Verkehrswende weiter vorangetrieben wird
dann Verkehrssicherheit gibt es nur mit
sicheren Radwegen das ist ein Thema was
zum Beispiel bisher in den
Koalitionsgesprächen an keinster Stelle
genannt wurde was mich doch ein bisschen
ratlos macht wenn man bedenkt dass dort
in den letzten Jahren sehr viel passiert
ist und auch sehr viel Wunsch in der
Bevölkerung war dort eben mehr
Verkehrssicherheit hergestellt wird wir
werden beim Bereich Mieterschutz nicht
locker lassen denn eines der zentralen
Themen die wir in diesem Wahlkampf
erlebt haben war das Thema
Wohnungsknappheit bezahlbarer Wohnraum
der nicht vorhanden ist und ich habe mit
Freude zu Kenntnis genommen dass die CDU
jetzt sich auch diesem Thema für die
Bundesebene annehmen wird und da verfügt
er die Berliner CDU mit Mario Ciao ja
auch über gute Kontakte und wenn auch
aus der Opposition da der Wille für
Mieterschutz kommt in der
länderöffnungsklausel damit wir hier in
Berlin auch ein mietendeckel
vorantreiben können und die Decken die
Mieten tatsächlich regulieren können wer
das glaube ich wirklich gut ähm weil
unsere Zeit langsam drängt das war jetzt
sozusagen das Stichwort für mich ich
bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei Ihnen
sind gegeben war das
Fraktionsvorsitzende von Bündnis 90 die
Grünen in Berlin